when we're young we're innocently brave
and we fearlessly dream about what our
lives might be like
maybe you wanted to be an astronaut or a
rocket scientist
maybe you dreamed of traveling to every
continent
since i was very young i dreamed of
working for the united nations in some
of the most difficult countries in the
world
and thanks to a lot of courage
that dream came true
but here's the thing about courage it
doesn't just appear whenever we need it
it's the result of tough reflection and
real work involving the balance between
fear and bravery
without fear we'll do foolish things
and without courage we'll never step
into the unknown
the balance of the two is where the
magic lies and it's a balance we all
deal with every day
first a word about my fancy wheels
i haven't always used a wheelchair i
grew up like many of you running jumping
and dancing i love
to dance
however in my mid twenties i began to
experience a series of inexplicable
falls
and a few years later i was diagnosed
with a recessive genetic condition
called hereditary inclusion body
myopathy or hibm
it's a progressive muscle wasting
disease that affects all of my muscles
from head to toe hibm is very rare
in the united states there are less than
200 people diagnosed
to date there is no approved treatment
or cure
and within 10 to 15 years of its onset
hibm typically leads to quadriplegia
which is why i now use a wheelchair
when i was first diagnosed everything
changed
it was frightening news because i had no
experience with chronic illness or
disabilities
and i had no idea how the disease might
progress
but what was most disheartening was to
listen to other people advise me to
limit my ambitions and dreams
and to change my expectations of what to
expect from life
you should quit your international
career
no one will marry you this way
you would be selfish to have children
the fact that someone who wasn't me was
putting limitations on my dreams and
ambitions was preposterous
and unacceptable
so i ignored them
[Applause]
i did get married
and i decided for myself not to have
children
and i continued my career with the
united nations
after my diagnosis going to work for two
years in angola a country recovering
from 27 years of brutal civil war
however it would be another five years
until i officially declared my diagnosis
to my employer because i was afraid that
they would question my capacity to
manage and i'd lose my job
i was working in countries where polio
had been common so when i overheard
someone say that they thought i might
have survived polio
i thought my secret was safe
no one asked why i was limping
so i didn't say anything
it took me over a decade to internalize
the severity of hibm
even as basic tasks and functions became
increasingly difficult
yet i continued to pursue my dream of
working all over the world and was even
appointed as a disability focal point
for unicef in haiti where i served for
two years after the devastating 2010
earthquake
and then my work brought me to the
united states and even as the disease
progressed significantly and i needed
leg braces and a walker to get around
i still longed for adventure
this time i started dreaming of a grand
outdoor adventure
and what's more grand
then the grand canyon
did you know that for every five million
people who visit the rim only one
percent go down to the canyon's base
i wanted to be a part of that one
percent
the only thing is
the only thing is is that the grand
canyon isn't exactly accessible
i was going to need some assistance to
get down the 5 000 foot descent of
vertical loose terrain
now when i face obstacles fear doesn't
necessarily immediately set in because i
assume that one way or another
i'll figure it out
and in this case my thought was
well if i can't walk down
i could learn to ride a horse
so that's what i did
and with that faithful decision began a
four-year commitment tossing back and
forth between fear and courage to
undertake a 12-day expedition four days
on horseback to cross grand canyon rim
to rim and eight days rafting
miles of the colorado river all with the
film crew in tow
spoiler alert we made it but not without
showing me how my deepest fear can
somehow manifest a mere response of
equal courage
on april 13
2018 sitting eight feet above the ground
riding a mustang horse named sheriff my
first impression of grand canyon was one
of shock
and terror
who knew i had a fear of heights
but there was no giving up now
i mustered up every ounce of courage
inside me to not let my fear get the
best of me
embarking on the south rim all i could
do to keep myself composed was to
breathe deeply stare up into the clouds
and
focus on my team's voices
but then
in the first hour
disaster struck
unable to hold myself upright in the
saddle going down an oversized step i
flung forward and smacked my face on the
back of the horse's head there was panic
my head hurt fiercely but the path was
too narrow for us to dismount
only at the halfway point at 2300 feet
at least another two hours down could we
stop and remove my helmet and see the
egg size bump protruding from my
forehead
for all of that planning and gear how is
it that we didn't even have an ice pack
luckily for all of us the swelling came
outwards and would drain into my face as
two fantastic black eyes which is an
amazing way to look in a documentary
film
[Applause]
this was not an easy peaceful journey
and yet that was exactly the point even
though i was afraid to get back into the
saddle i got back in the descent alone
to the canyon floor took a total of 10
hours and that was just a one of four
riding
next came the mighty rapids the colorado
river and the grand canyon has some of
the highest white water in the country
and just to be prepared in case we
should capsize we'd practice having me
swim through a smaller rapid and it's
safe to say it wasn't glamorous
i took my breath in the wrong part of
the wave choked on river water and was
unable to steer myself
yes it was scary but it was also
fantastic
waterfalls slick canyons and a couple
billion years of bedrock that seemed to
change color throughout the day the
grand canyon is true wilderness and
worthy of all of its accolades
[Applause]
the expedition all that planning and the
trip itself
showed me a level of fear i had never
experienced before
but more importantly it showed me how
boldly courageous i can be
my grand canyon journey was not easy
this was not a vision of an amazonian
woman effortlessly making her way
through epic scenery
this was me crying
exhausted and beat up with two black
eyes
it was scary
it was stressful
it was exhilarating
now that the trip is over it's easy to
be blase about what we achieved
i know i want to raft the river again
this time all
277 miles of it
but i also know that i would never do
the horseback riding part again
it's just too dangerous
and that's my real point
i'm not just here to show you my film
footage
i'm here to remind us all that life is
really just a lesson in finding the
balance between fear and courage in
understanding what is and what isn't a
good idea
life is already scary so for our dreams
to come true we need to be brave
in facing my fears and finding the
courage to push through them i swear my
life has been extraordinary
so live big and try to let your courage
outweigh your fear you never know where
it might take you
thank you
[Applause]